les russes ils disent poids parce qu'il
ya plein de réactions de gens qui
disaient les seuls à parts égales et
chinois et les sols sinon qu'ils peuvent
faire reculer vladimir poutine peuple
c'est la population c'est le peuple est
ce que c'est possible ça va oui c'est
possible mais pour le moment je lui dis
qu'en russie il n'ya pas de peuple il
n'y a pas de piège de la populace et de
la population mais il n'y a pas de si
l'audience est allé c'est à dire que en
ukraine en huit ans poutine a créé une
nation mais la clé une nation qui est
fier de son de son pays qui élit ses
présidents qui s'est organisée cbc pas
rose c'est il ya plein de corruption
c'est il ya tout un tas de trucs qui
marchent pas mais c'est une nation c'est
y compris dans la religion parce qu'il y
avait une église orthodoxe russe qui
était en ukraine et qui dictaient ausy
craignent à ce qu'il fallait faire dans
les églises ils ont ils ont réussi à se
mettre contre le patriarcat de moscou
ils ont obtenu le tome hausse des
patriarches de
universel et maintenant ils sont fiers
c'est que parce que il faut pas oublier
la russie a commencé à kiev la russie a
commencé aux 8e 9e siècle accueillait
moscovie à cette époque là il y avait
des ours il n'y avait rien zéro la
mouche kobe est devenu plus ou moins un
état normal six siècles après alors
je supporte pas d'autre donc le peuple
pour vous c'est impossible non c'est pas
impossible mais c'est difficile c'est
difficile parce que en fait personne est
ce que vous allez vous avez envie de
prendre des armes pour aller faire la
guerre personne n'a envie de ça et donc
mais en revanche c'est aussi la
faiblesse la faiblesse de russie non
mais est-ce qui est ce qu'ils ont fait
ce qu'ils ont ce qu'ils peuvent faire
est-ce qu'ils sont solidaires de poutine
est maintenant quasi
et solidaires près de la moitié solide
d'accord parce qu'il ya toujours des
gens qui des votes en guerre qui a qui
sont venues avec moi qu'il est non oui
mais la moitié tant qu'ils sont devant
leur télé avec le frigo plein à la
maison si on leur demande d'aller
restriction des restrictions de l'orée
des élections de l'europe commence à
marcher et quand il ya les cercueils des
gamins qui vont arriver de l'ukraine
parce que déjà
on en a parlé hier des chiffres vous
savez en ukraine il ya quatre fois plus
de russes actuellement qui sont tués que
deux clients et donc du coup et commence
à recevoir des cercueils il ya déjà les
maires il ya l'organisation très
puissante en russie les maires des
soldats elle commence déjà à haradheere
fini bah ça ça ça pète ça c'est pas rien
il ya mieux même à l'intérieur de
l'ukraine il ya quelque chose je suis
tombé hier de la chaîne le métropolite
onofri qui est le dirigeant de l'église
orthodoxe du patriarcat de moscou en
ukraine il a dit il faut cesser
immédiatement cette guerre donc ça c'est
vrai pourtant c'est quelqu'un qui est
considéré comme un agent de poutine à
l'intérieur de l'ambassade donc c'est
peut-être été plusieurs à vie comme ça
plusieurs personnes comme ça qu'il
pourrait faire votre langue encore une
veine encore une personne le général et
va chauffer leonid ivashov c'est ça qui
était un général quasiment dans un
environnement militaire ce et on rit il
ya trois semaines il a écrit une lettre
il a appelé à la démission du commandant
en chef c'est ça il a appelé tous les
officiers ça peut jouer sur le dit
mi-août marc oui bah oui c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il est attaqué est ce que
la chine peut aider la russie à tenir et
vladimir poutine malgré les restrictions
des européens je crois que la chine ne
voudra pas s'engager ouvertement pour la
chine ne le fait pas christophe qui a
travaillé en afrique et il peut dire que
la chine en afrique il fait pas pas vus
comme des russes sur les chinois etc les
chinois car l'afrique appartient aux
chinois ouais mais personne ne sait pas
ce qu'ils sont là ils sont discrets et
mène jamais de guerre c'est pas oui en
réalité
la chine et les russes sont les nouveaux
colons bien évidemment de l'afrique les
français les français les vrais colons
et colons armés qui font qu'il faut
vraiment pas de cadeau à la population
et qui tue la population sont les russes
actuellement mais les chinois
travaillent en sous sol travail ils
arrivent avec leurs containers et
travaille pendant deux ans ils prennent
le sous sol ils font pas de bruit ces
monnaies on a l'adresse où vraiment
qu'il ya une alliance russo chinoises
pendant qu'il s'est créées quand même
maintenant non non c'est souvent la
chine c'est le seul pays qui ne s'est
pas déclarée
voilà contre l'attack en ukraine seul
c'est un des seuls clubs et
la chine était très très timide années
la chine c'est un peuple d'à 1,1
milliard et demi population énorme
puissance économique et militaire et qui
regarde la sibérie et l'extrême orient
russe et dit poutine vas-y fais ta
guerre tu vas tu es obligé tu vas être
tu es tu perds un million par an en / /
/ / coup en demi et nous n'attendons un
à temps on est là et les nanas et 11 i
haute-sûre sur ton territoire